how much
did
our argument against the clippers
[Music]
drive you
to ultimately divorce
what's up man i appreciate you coming on
it's my show chips obviously it stems
from exploring that chip on your
shoulder what drives us and makes us who
we are and why we here today so thank
you no doubt man thanks for having me
bro for taking me on the journey coach
brown your first coach how was that and
what did he teach you he taught me the
fundamentals
i mean it felt like fundamentals of the
game but it was like truly fundamental
to life what it's going to take for me
to survive as a human being a maturing
human being he put this game in front of
me told me the fundamentals of it the
balance of the game the history of it i
just started to
understand that for one but also started
to see life a little bit clearer too it
was one of those special times in my
life that i always revert back to you
know you hear the cliche saying of
everything you do do a game speed to me
that is the most cliche
statement in the world yeah except for
when it comes to you you actually do
every rep game speed does that come from
him or does that come from somewhere
else yeah
he built the foundation and the cliche
stu i mean i am cliche i mean i'm simple
i'm efficient i'm to the point that's
what my game is and all the best stuff
to me is cliche so i just tried to
approach every workout like a game every
game like a workout and then you go to
high school and and you went to
several different high school years how
did you feel about that then and looking
back
on that how do you feel about it now so
back then i didn't know it was any
different i was listening to my coach
brown my mom my pops like this was where
the best competition was so i would
switch schools every year to move up a
level people have tried to make that
connection of you
being at several different high schools
to now you being on three different
teams what do you say to that or those
people yeah i mean i feel as though at
each spot even at high school my game
was growing so fast i need to be in a
different environment to see how far i
can go and and why why texas in my
opinion texas is a football school yeah
it is it is it's a football state but
underneath all of that is some
incredible athletes on the basketball
side it was this perfect situation and
then being in austin it was like you
know the city itself you know it wasn't
a normal college town it was like being
in a major city so it was perfect for me
i know growing up in saginaw for me
being the tallest kid everybody always
wanted wanted me to play center and
i was fortunate enough to have my uncle
who just taught me how to dribble and
taught me guard skills
but i still always end up throwing at
the center whereas you're seven feet uh
you'll never admit it but you're setting
feet
you never played before in your life
until you came to go to state really and
i played a little bit in college because
i couldn't dribble that well but i was
still on a perimeter most of the time
and when we went small that's when you
would play the four whose idea was it
like to never just stick you on the
block cause you were always taller than
everybody coach brown and coach chucky
like they would see me every day just
running up and down a court like no ball
in my hand just running around with kids
and they seen my agility outside running
playing football and stuff so they seen
that i wasn't just a stiff so so you're
calling me a steph all right
i mean
no i got no stuff though and you're not
even big oh you're like six six like
and you play bigger than what you really
are but most guys that's tall and skinny
they can't really move at the same time
and uh you know i always wanted to be a
point guard and shooting guard i was
just growing so fast so some coaches did
just stick me underneath the basket but
if i get a rebound i'd go coast to coast
you know what i'm saying if i if i shoot
a jump shot here and there so i was
showing flashes but it wasn't like this
you know what i'm saying i developed
this over time i remember
reading a statement where you said
i'm tired of being number two i was the
number two pick
i was the number two player in the
country where was that coming from like
in why
did you feel that like
yeah cause we had just lost it in the
finals
and i felt like we was right there every
game and people was like man good job
man y'all did great like you guys are
young i'll be right back and i was like
i don't care about that i wanted to win
that series and i want to win a
championship and that's where that came
from i was just
people wanted me to accept being second
so much that was never my mentality ever
always to win the game and you know i
appreciated people like respecting my
game but i wanted more for myself and at
that point that's how i was feeling
first nine years in okc and then you
decide
that you leaving okc and
you ultimately decide to come to the
warriors knowing that
the scrutiny would be there um
knowing that
you know everybody would say the
warriors were this great team
but you still ultimately made the
decision
why was that was that driven by i don't
give a [ __ ] with y'all i think this is
good for me
or was that just
you know uh was it strictly just a
basketball decision it was a basketball
decision but i knocked down the like not
giving a [ __ ] ladder with that too you
know what i'm saying it kind of knocked
down two birds with one stone with that
but it was mainly
i felt like i was the absolute perfect
fit with what you guys were doing
on both days of the bar and i knew my
game had reached a point where i needed
to really see what that looked like and
i thought that was just
a no-brainer i would do that [ __ ] a
million times you know again i would i
didn't second guess at all and i knew
that's what i wanted to do when i was
going into these meetings but i really
just had to confirm go through the
process but like i knew from watching
the games just looking at interviews
just seeing everything that you're all
about it's like that's the way i wanted
to play and that's the way i need to go
to you know continue to keep getting
better as a player once i tunnel vision
on that i knew everything would come
afterwards and it was just just me going
through that experience and see how i
was going to deal with it and
[ __ ] it was it went it went perfect you
didn't do three years there two
championships would have been three had
you not got hurt easily but in my
opinion after year two
you were over it you were done with it
and you were on to the next thing but we
had the opportunity to three-peat and in
my mind what brought you back to going
to state for year three was just the
opportunity of three people but it
didn't feel right for you no more am i
right wrong that's interesting because a
lot of people that's just a talk around
me the last few years and i get what
people are saying because before i got
to go to state i was just happy go lucky
like just bright eyed to the experience
not knowing what was ahead by first year
i knew exactly what we needed to do in
order for us to win every night i knew
what my role was to the team teams
before i didn't quite know what my role
was every night did i have to be the
scorer did i have to be the facilitator
that had to get other guys involved i
had to make threes i knew exactly what
my role was and i locked on it with so
much focus and determination to not [ __ ]
around every day and you've seen it from
workouts to practices shoot arounds film
i was super locked in and made people on
the outside look at me like hold on is
he enjoying this when i dive into
something like that with that level of
focus i don't want to be anywhere else
in life that's the most
enjoyable
experience i ever had after that first
one if that was the case i wouldn't have
played 78 games that year i would just
wait it to the end of the season and try
to plan the playoffs i play every game
i went hard every day
i cared about every matchup no matter
who was on the floor just my look that
feels as like
energetic or opening as it was before
and i liked that i liked that i was
closed off and focused on my work i just
maybe should have communicated that with
more people who were interested in
knowing what i was going through but
i had the most fun locking in
and
and completing the task you know what
i'm saying because i knew he was going
to win every night
and it's rare to get to that point as an
nba player you know you're going to win
every night so i just try to focus and
stay in the moment more than anything
and for my for my own personal
um
sanity
because i've been getting my eyes kicked
ever since you left so just for my own
personal sanity how much
did
our argument
against the clippers
drive you
to ultimately lead the warriors it
wasn't the argument it was the the way
that everybody steve kerr act like it
didn't happen bob myers and tried to
just discipline you and think that that
would put the mask over everything i
really felt like that was such a big
situation for us as a group the first
time we went through something like that
we had to get that [ __ ] all out i
remember watching the last dance
and when scotty didn't go into the game
the whole team in the locker room said
scotty that was [ __ ] up that you did
that we needed that we just needed to
throw all of that [ __ ] out on the table
and say yo jay
okay like that was [ __ ] up that we
even had to go through that let's just
wipe our hands with that and go go
finish the task i don't think we did
that we tried to dance around it i just
didn't like how all of that just the
vibe between all of that it just made
[ __ ] weird to me and i'd rather us
be who we say we are family first
communication is key like we didn't show
that and that's what rubbed me the wrong
way more than anything when we landed
back from la
i sat in the
hazel was sitting in the car for an hour
and 45 minutes they pulled me in that
room at signature for an hour and 45
minutes and they try to tell me
you need to apologize
and i told them
i'll talk to kay but y'all aren't going
to tell me what i need to say
and you know they went on for hour and
45 minutes saying a bunch of [ __ ]
and ultimately they realized all right
we're not getting through to him we're
gonna try again in the morning
and so we met the next morning and
they said all right
you slept on it you ready to apologize
and i told them right then and there i
said
y'all about to [ __ ] this up
i said the only person that can make
this right
it's me and kay
and there's nothing that y'all can do
and y'all are going to [ __ ] this up and
in my opinion they [ __ ] it up i think
so too
and
they told me right then and they're like
we're going to suspend you for this game
i laughed and it literally laughed in
their face
and bob said to me he said um
wow
that was not the reaction i was looking
for or expecting and i said well either
i'm gonna laugh in your face or i'm
gonna cuss you the [ __ ] out so you pick
i'ma choose laughs so i think what
you're doing is funny
and so i'm alive and so it's interesting
to hear you say
essentially the same thing that i told
them that day
but uh you know and moving past that um
kind of along those same lines you've
now played with russ who i think has an
incredible chip on his shoulder that
sometimes goes too far
[Music]
myself who has a chip on my shoulder
that sometimes go
too far
kyrie who has a chip on his shoulder
that sometimes goes too far and james
who has a chip on his shoulder that
probably sometimes goes too far
and playing with all the guys that you
play with that you can say ah he
probably go way too far
we all go too far bro and we all got
major chips on our shoulders there's a
million of us imagine a million people
trying to walk run into this door right
now
somebody will get elbow
kicked
pushed over like we all trying to fit
into a one pick spot
a hundred millions of us trying to fit
into these 12 15 spots on teams so we
got to have that chip on our shoulder
and i always appreciate that appreciate
the people that acknowledge that it's
tough to make it to the league and i had
to kick a lot of [ __ ] down to
get here i had to
shun a lot of my friends and a lot of
sacrifice a lot of the personal [ __ ]
that i loved as a kid so i can get here
so we all all of us naturally are
underdogs got chips on our shoulders
because it's hard to make it to this
point
but the person that went too far was
always draymond green
he
he uh i mean to the point where i felt
like you were trying to establish
that you're not playing around like
you're not gonna walk over me even
though i was a second round pick and i'm
undersized and i'm i'm not as skilled as
y'all want me to be or i don't play the
way y'all traditionally like for people
my size to play i felt that same way
about russell westbrook because of his
story i felt the same way about james
hard because i know his story from like
when these dudes was kids what they had
to go through as everyday people not
just on a court it's hard to make it
through life every day you know what i'm
saying where some of these people come
from you know so i started understanding
that about people i'm realizing like now
i see why they show their ego they show
the pride that they have they show
the chip that they have on their
shoulder because it's hard as [ __ ] to
make it every day you know what i'm
saying but you pushed it to the limit
where it's like it's cool for me to be
who i am
and be
and not apologize for it all the time
because you don't mean you ain't mean no
harm to anybody but [ __ ] that you want
it done you want it done and i we all
respected that and we all kind of looked
up to that as guys that come into the
league and want to fit into this system
so bad you know what i'm saying like
wanting to be a part of this whole thing
then you realize you see dudes who just
going by their own little patients like
that's more so in my rhythm you know
what i'm saying so a lot of the guys
that i played were from russ to james to
staff to clay they all kind of moved at
the beat of their own drum that
encourages a lot of people to do the
same [ __ ] not just basketball players
but people in general who just watch us
dealing with everybody every single day
i started thinking like that and i
started seeing the beauty and all of
this [ __ ]
to watch you early on in your career
like you said you was the happy one you
was the kid that carried the backpack
nike started a backpack line because
and you to this day you still carry your
backpack all the time um and so there's
this common misconception that you're
not
the kid that carries the backpack
anymore i still think you're the kid
that loves basketball and carry a
backpack yeah but
over the course of the years your
answers
to the me how you deal with the media
has changed
why is that is that just who you grew
into as that because of the way they act
with certain [ __ ] where did that
i felt like the media knew more than me
i almost had them on a pedestal of like
they got more history knowledge of the
game they more experience than me in
this area of the nba so once i started
to get more experience and realize like
oh no
they can never be
what i am or know what i know
or understand it the way i understand it
some of the questions you know they
didn't seem so intelligent to me anymore
people wanted to praise me more than i
liked or
hate me more than i like make a big deal
out of so much other [ __ ] i was just
like you know this game is simple to me
so some of the stuff that you're asking
really doesn't move me the way it used
to i just you know start to see life
different i can see this game different
so you know
of course my
answers and questions you know about
what goes on is going to be different
too so i just chalk that up to just
maturity and experience
and speaking of media uh social media
obviously
we were teammates when you when you got
caught with the burner account
one thing i love
about the burner account is
everything that you said on the burner
account you just started to say on kevin
durant's account yeah a lot of people
don't like it as you know most people
voice they don't like how you
respond to some fans or how you respond
to this how you are always tweeting what
do you make of people's reaction to you
responding to fans and if you think
something you send it yeah i just think
people are still upset that i went to
the warriors and a lot of people who are
cavs fans who
enjoy watching the cavs beat y'all
before
which is a lot of people i didn't
realize that i got it a lot of people
enjoyed seeing y'all lose in 2016.
and a lot of those people were upset
that we were so good and they're still
upset
because you do the same [ __ ] on twitter
damian lillard does the same [ __ ] on
twitter cj mccullum does the same [ __ ]
on twitter we all do the same [ __ ] on
twitter but for me it's a problem i mean
i chalk it up to just me being so good
at what i do
and playing with a team that was so
great and we fit so well nobody likes a
great thing
and i was i guess i was the cause of
that
great thing because i came and joined so
it's way deeper than what i do on
twitter and i understand that and it's
funny to me at this point because you
can't race what we did you never gonna
race it and you know you love watching
us play
you know what i'm saying so
i think it's the best ever basketball
ever in my opinion but that's really
what it is so many people still upset
with me that i chose to play basketball
for the golden state warriors which is
sad at this point because it's almost a
decade later
since i made that decision you know what
i'm saying that's never going to stop me
from engaging with fans because at the
end of the day i'm only talking about
basketball i'm not diving into politics
i'm not telling you how you should live
i'm not flexing my money or my power or
none of that you know you i'm just
literally talking about the game you
know and what i see and i don't think it
harms anyone i would love to see d book
win a championship
but in my opinion
the finals does not compare to
warriors
cavs warriors none
even even warriors raptors do you have
any regrets about that knowing that we
probably would have won five more
championships
no i don't have any regrets at all i
felt like we did exactly what we were
supposed to do
and i wish you the three-peater because
that's rare and we were like right there
but i don't have any regrets at all
because i feel like if we just stay
healthy with the nets we had a great
chance of finishing too
so
no i mean
being hurt for that year really changed
my perspective on everything i was doing
and everything i did before i looked at
that time with playing with the warriors
is
so special to me but it was time to move
on
so now
you're you're you're in this space with
the nets
and you know everybody has made this big
deal about kyrie and
you know his beliefs and
him missing games and just like we all
do he got his [ __ ] yeah and a lot of
people are now saying that is what's
going to cost y'all
ultimately of reaching where y'all want
to reach what do you make of that i mean
i just think people don't like kyrie
because he wanted to leave cleveland and
he wanted to leave boston i don't think
he's any deeper than that
he doesn't harm anyone he hasn't said
anything that's disrespectful to anybody
his game is beautiful to watch i just
think people don't like the decisions on
what he chooses to play
and they they sort of amplify everything
because everybody in this league has
their [ __ ] they may say something
over a course of six months that may
everybody may not agree with that's just
nature to our business you know when
you're that good at what you do
everything is low amplified and
sometimes it's a little extra and also
what kyrie does especially in our
building nobody is making a big deal out
of it just like a lot of [ __ ] we did in
our building we didn't give a [ __ ] if
clay missed practice right
who longs you there for the game as long
as you you know you healthy enough to
play like you give a [ __ ] like when you
you and coach cursed each other out
literally as soon as the practice was
over it was cool like you know so it was
like everybody's mature enough to
understand like we come to work we
handle our business and you be who you
are
family you have no kids you know 32.
i got i got three kids i'm 31 so i you
know i took a little different route now
man but you have no kids why do you want
kids ultimately do you not want kids i
mean that's a that's a big commitment
for one and i always felt like i was
just really zoned in on my work in my
long time and my free time
uh too much for me to like lock in or
something like that you know and
eventually i do want that but the older
i get i think is the better because i'm
trying more knowing myself more
understanding my situation a little bit
more so if i were to invite someone in
or combine my life with another person
you know it'd be perfectly perfect at
this time as opposed to me 10 years ago
i wouldn't know what to do so i think
i'm as long as i wait you know
it's only gonna be for the better
do you ever worry that
the longer you wait
your kid won't understand who kevin
durant is i'm glad he won't understand
because i don't want him to have to feel
like he's pressured in this bubble to do
what i did you know and as long as i'm
playing like this bubble was always
going to be about making it to the nba
so if you see a little kd out here
nothing but you expecting him to be a
basketball player so like i don't know
if my kid or even gonna be that tall or
fall into the game like i fell into it
who knows so i'd rather just me tell
them you know over time what i did i
don't want any pressure for anybody just
coming into my world to do what i like
to do i want to explore things on their
own
so what's next for you you got um you
know probably 10 more years left for who
i hope so
what comes after that have you gotten
there yet are you still just so locked
in on basketball it's just that i'll
definitely want to stay involved in the
game
i'm learning so much now i don't know
where i could use it at coaching gm
ownership
i feel like i'm gathering so much
knowledge that i could be useful in any
part of this game
but outside of that i have other
interest in
tech world
media space
art all of that stuff that you know i
enjoy doing my leisure time you know i
want to get involved in at some point
but for now you know what i'm about
you know what i mean what i enjoy to do
every day so until that time is up then
we'll see what happens but i feel like
i'm setting up stuff on the back end of
things that i can have options
you know i think people look at us and
they say oh man
you play basketball
for a living you should be happy which
is great right like you love basketball
i love basketball being able to do that
and make the type of money we make is
incredible
but with that comes a lot of [ __ ]
scrutiny comes a lot of headaches what
is the happiest you've been as a
professional i don't even i don't even
like to use the word happiness that's
just a fleeting feeling it can just go
so up and down i don't want to chase
that feeling it's just not a
efficient way for me to live i feel like
just
having peace and
and really
simply just enjoying being alive every
day is the best place for me to be you
know i don't want to be happy and sad
like i don't even want to have to go
through that i just want to just kind of
flow through life i experience so much i
just want to take on every experience
for what it is and enjoy it at the
moment you know i don't want to chase
happiness you know so i just try to stay
even i respect that
appreciate it bro man that was
incredible
thank you thank you doubt that's true
this is gonna be an incredible interview
by the way
this is gonna go crazy
[Music]